Fire Emblem 3 houses was a Smash Hit for
Nintendo both critically and
commercially while it didn't
dramatically shake up the combat its
ambitious multi-campaign structure swung
for the fences it only seemed natural
that Nintendo and developer intelligent
systems would build off three House's
success while Fire Emblem engage
certainly Builds on the deep and
rewarding tactical combat the
predictable story and repetitive side
activities feel like a step backward for
the long-running series
foreign
foreign
[Music]
gauge follows a more traditional
structure than three houses
calendar-based progression your time is
split between the Tactical turn-based
combat the series is known for and a
hub-like area where you can interact
with other characters and outfit your
units with weapons and equipment while
there are multiple missions available to
you at any given time this story sticks
to a linear structure as you plot a
course around the map there are no major
story decisions and apart from a couple
characters found an optional paralog
chapters everyone will recruit the same
characters at the same time the
traditional structure isn't inherently a
Bad Thing some of the best games in the
series follow this narrative style and
engages presentation and narrative are
more polished thanks to its focused
design but this approach also puts the
story in a brighter Spotlight and
unfortunately the extra polish doesn't
hide the predictable and Meandering plot
which overall Falls flat you play as
alier's son or daughter of the Divine
dragon and it's your destiny to save the
world from the fell Dragon the premise
is standard jrpg fare and although there
are some twists and turns along the way
these rarely feel like meaningful
developments you and your crew are the
good guys while the evil purple dragon
and its followers are the bad guys while
not perfect three houses approach of
pitting different houses against each
other and forcing you to make some huge
decisions along the way was both
ambitious and encouraged personal
investment engage's story on the other
hand feels safe and formulaic so it can
be easy to become detached from it no
way
ah no way
the Divine dragon is finally away
as you travel the world you'll meet an
Eclectic cast of characters and visit
some vibrant locales that surface
battlefields the stakes are high from
the outset and the plot rarely gives you
time to learn about or appreciate its
large cast of characters outside of a
few key figures who are critical to The
Story characters early on are introduced
in Rapid succession and after a few
battles I had forgotten about some of
them entirely most of the
characterization happens in optional
support cutscenes but given how bloated
the roster is at the beginning some
characters naturally fell to the Wayside
and as a result were way too under level
to properly utilize the mechanical
impact of the skewed social elements at
play is that in the early hours the
large number of bodies May offset some
losses you might incur on classic Mode
which is fire emblems Perma Death Mode
however engages pretty forgiving on the
normal and hard difficulties so in
reality you probably won't lose any
units on classic Mode either and
regardless of which difficulty you
choose there is a mechanic that allows
you to rewind time to correct any of
your mistakes normal difficulty gives
you an unlimited number of rewinds while
the hard and maddening difficulties
limit it to 10. despite Fire Emblem
engages forgiving nature it is a
well-balanced experience regardless of
the difficulty mode you choose normal
offers a reasonable challenge for
players who might not want to utilize
every system the game offers while hard
delivers a tough experience that
requires tactical forethought and some
preparation outside of battle in
maddening demands strategic prowess and
full investment in all of Fire Emblem
gauges various systems I'm currently a
quarter of the way through a maddening
playthrough and it's harrowing the odds
seem insurmountable at first but the
right planning will eventually lead you
to victory the combat itself is tighter
than ever the Tactical tile-based
skirmish's return as well as the
original rock paper scissors style
weapon triangle sword speed axes axis
beat Spears and Spears beat swords apart
from Fire Emblem 3 houses the weapon
triangle has been a Mainline series
Mainstay since 19 96's Fire Emblem
genealogy of the holy war and engage
brings some tweaks to the system weapon
advantages not only deal extra damage
but cause a break effect which is a
mechanic new to engage when an offensive
unit inflicts a break onto a defending
unit that unit drops their weapon and is
incapable of counter-attacking for the
remainder of the Skirmish and one
additional Skirmish during the same turn
the brake mechanic adds more risk and
reward to the weapon triangle by giving
weapon type specific purposes and use
cases making a well-balanced team
crucial with a proper coordination you
can effectively undercut your opponent's
entire counter-attack effort leaving
your units unscathed until the enemies
turn naturally your opponents can also
take advantage of the weapon triangle
and break your units if you aren't
careful while it can briefly put you on
the back foot on the normal difficulty
it can be a matter of life and death on
hard or maddening taking full advantage
of the weapon triangle requires clever
positioning a balance team and
well-equipped units that can cover up
potential weaknesses on the Fly
[Music]
I live to fight again
fire emblem's highlighted mechanic is
the engage feature throughout engage's
story you will come across emblem rings
that house the spirit of past Fire
Emblem Heroes along with stat Buffs
units equipped with an emblem ring can
merge with the Fire Emblem hero
contained within it to utilize unique
weapons and skills for three turns for
example a unit paired with sigured the
blue haired protagonist from genealogy
of the holy war can use a skill called
override which can attack multiple units
in a single file line
one strike will decide at all
additionally sigurd's ring allows the
user to move a few extra spaces after
attacking allowing you to leave room for
another unit to follow up Lucina on the
other hand has a flashy skill called all
for one which allows all friendly units
within two spaces to partake in a
powerful chain attack with proper
coordination all for one can deliver a
deadly blow to some of the game's
tougher enemies there are 12 rings at
all and each represents a different
Mainline Fire Emblem game most of Fire
Emblem engages depth is built around
these emblem Rings any unit can use an
emblem ring and as a unit battles
alongside an emblem the bond between
that unit and the emblem ring increases
as the character improves their bond
with an emblem they can inherit new
skills and permanent stat Buffs which
can be purchased with skill points while
certain emblem abilities and skills
complement specific classes there is
nothing stopping you from giving an
emblem ring to any one of your units the
combinations are endless and it can be
satisfying to find both the perfect Duo
and an unconventional pairing it is
imperative to carefully consider which
unit should get which emblem ring though
not only for the Tactical Advantage but
because maxing out a bond between an
emblem and a unit can be a time sink it
could take dozens of battles to max out
an emblem's bond with a specific
character and if you've given that
emblem ring to a character who can't
fully utilize its inherited skills you
could be wasting your time there are
ways to speed up the bonding process but
they require Bond fragments which can
also be used to forge and meld stat
buffing Bond Rings the central pedestal
the place where you can manage all your
rings will tell you if a specific
inherited skill overlaps with another
however it does not tell you who and
which class would benefit most from a
specific emblem ring there are even some
cases where the story will introduce a
new unit pre-equipped with an emblem
ring that isn't all that beneficial for
them to wield so it's up to you to
recognize that and find a unit who might
get more out of that emblem ring
managing emblem rings can be
overwhelming especially for newcomers
who may not fully understand all of Fire
Emblem stats but once you've put
together a a balance crew that fully
utilizes all 12 emblem Rings the combat
sings the unique abilities especially
when paired with the right unit give you
an edge that begins to build momentum as
you tear through the enemy's numbers and
knowing that you have a well-balanced
team with specific emblem rings that
only informs your strategy from the
outset but it also allows you to adjust
In the Heat of the battle should you
encounter a tough situation and this
happens without any one emblem ring
feeling overpowered the end result is
that the combat remains fresh throughout
the game's lengthy run time
foreign
[Music]
well the emblems bring a lot of nuance
and experimentation to the combat they
are all one-dimensional characters off
the battlefield apart from Marth the
emblems don't add anything substantial
to the overall narrative occasionally
they'll pop in for a cut scene to
deliver a line or two when you first
meet but after that they are relegated
to truncated soulless Bond conversations
and paralogs that act as straightforward
loyalty missions there's a paralog for
each of the emblem rings and the setup
for all of them is nearly identical you
show up to a place that looks familiar
to the emblem's Homeworld the emblem
asks you to prove yourself in combat and
then you fight while some of the battles
themselves are interesting the setups
for these paralogs never are these
missions could have been the perfect
opportunity to revisit and expand on fan
favorite characters like Lucina and Lynn
or give more personality to the player
characters from past games like Corin
and bilith at the very least I was
hoping engage might be a good
introduction to characters that never
made it to the West like sigured and
leaf but that wasn't the case Fire
Emblem engage feels like an attempt to
leverage the series Rich history and
huge cast of beloved characters but
outside of some clever combat quirks
that reference the older games the
Emblem characters are paper thin a
handful of them also serve as a sobering
reminder that a portion of fire emblem's
history is still inaccessible in the
west fortunately the cast outside of the
emblem Rings is solid like previous
games most of the characterization is
done through short vignettes called
support conversations they can be funny
quirky and occasionally deep when they
explore a character's internal or
external struggles they're not all good
and some follow common jrpg tropes a
little too closely but in most cases
it's a joy to watch these characters
interact with each other one highlight
for me is Prince alcrest who has been
living in his brother's Shadow since he
was a kid most of allcrest support
conversations revolve around him getting
over his inferiority complex in unusual
ways
foreign
I threatened the Divine dragon and the
Crown Prince of firenay I'm begging
please find it in your hearts to forgive
me in one scene a party obsessed
companion invites him to a get-together
where allcrest is able to cut loose and
discover a side of himself he didn't
know existed in allcrest case it was fun
to watch him build up his confidence as
I was developing him into a cold-blooded
Archer on the battlefield by the end it
felt like all Chris character outside of
combat mirrored the character I had
molded him into on the battlefield not
every character has an arc like allcrest
but each of them has a distinct often
peculiar personality that keeps support
conversations fresh and light-hearted
some of these scenes can be a bit
awkward but they usually give you just
enough backstory to make you care about
them in battle most of these
conversations take place at the somnil
your base above the clouds here you can
chat with your companions exercise for
some temporary stat Buffs share a meal
with some friends fish take care of
livestock purchase and upgrade new
weapons feed the thumbnail spirit animal
saw me donate to one of the different
kingdoms battle-friendly units in the
arena and of course manage your emblem
Rings most of these activities reset
after each battle so you're encouraged
to return to the thumbnail often to make
the most of your time unfortunately it
doesn't take long before these
activities start to feel like busy work
while the support conversations are
generally great in tweaking your unit's
loadouts can be satisfying running
around the thumbnail to pick up
resources and partaking in these
activities is not the worst of the bunch
is a mini game that has you polish
emblem rings as the emblem hero
awkwardly Praises or chastises your work
handle that gently
I appreciate your upkeep of the Ring of
course you can skip all these activities
and focus solely on the battles but that
could put you at a significant
disadvantage especially on harder
difficulties in order to keep your
companions in Tip-Top shape and bring in
a steady flow of resources you'll need
to return to the somnia after each
battle whether you like it or not the
most substantial side activity in the
somnil is the Tower of Trials here you
can connect with other players for
asynchronous Co-Op and player versus
player game modes relay trials pits you
against an AI controlled team and has
you trade off with other players every
few turns once the trial is complete
everyone involved will receive some
rewards it's a neat idea that lets you
try out character builds created by
other players but it's not as compelling
as a standard battle since you could be
joining mid-fight with an unfamiliar
team a lot of tactical decision making
is out of your control losing an ally or
an entire battle due to another player's
poor decision making feels antithetical
to fire emblem's Core Design the async
synchronous PVP mode out realm trials
lets you or an opponent create a map and
scenario that other players can take on
the designer can place obstacles mounted
weapons and select their units to
populate the battlefield once the level
is complete it can be shared with
friends and strangers once again it's a
neat idea but there doesn't seem to be
any proper balancing or level scaling
within these trials I joined a random
match and the opponent's units were
under level to the point where I was
able to one hit all of them I can see
the appeal of sharing trials with
friends who are evenly matched but
hopping in random games seems unfair
without better skill based or balanced
considerations being made it is worth
noting that I tested out Rome trials
during a pre-release phase and a more
balanced matchmaking system could be in
place once the game is available to a
wider audience
foreign
[Music]
's biggest surprise is its presentation
engage is a noticeable upgrade when
compared to three houses character
models look much sharper with thick and
defined edges the pre-rendered cutscenes
are gorgeous and the battlefields are
more detailed not only does the game
look better on a technical level the art
Direction in engage feels much stronger
this time around characters are lavishly
rendered with colorful outfits and
accessories that perfectly capture their
personality Jean the young medic
brandishes a backpack equipped with
vials and a medicinal flask while
Diamante the Royal Prince of brodia is
adorned with heavy armor with red
accents to match his country's colors
even though engage does front load the
experience with too many characters they
all feel visually unique the flashy
battle animations go along nicely with
the colorful cast of characters as well
while you're likely to skip the standard
battle animations in the back half of
the game I still found myself sitting
through all of the extravagant emblem
attacks watching an enemy's health bar
plummet after unleashing an explosive
multi-hit attack is gratifying what
really hammers home the Stellar
presentation though is the incredible
score the sweeping orchestral
compositions Elevate tense battle
scenarios and Salvage some of the
dullest story beats just listen to this
for a bit
[Music]
foreign
thankfully you can replay any track from
your bedroom in the somnia including a
handful of tracks from previous entries
while fire emblem's combat mechanics
have never been better engages story and
structure lack the ambition of its
predecessors the result is a predictable
and straightforward romp that's carried
by its fantastic presentation and
engaging combat and although the emblem
rings at a deep satisfying wrinkle to
the battles the heroes contained within
them are one-dimensional apparitions
that leave a lot to be desired if you're
looking for a deep tactical RPG with
some colorful characters it will
certainly scratch that itch but beyond
that Fire Emblem gauge feels like a safe
straightforward entry in Nintendo's
long-running series
foreign
[Music]